the Joe Rogan experience and you know
they'll get to a point where it's gonna
be you know I think in my lifetime
there's gonna be some sort of armament
intervention in Mexico at some point
really
so you anticipate almost like in a civil
war I think something's gonna happen in
Mexico is going to destabilize it so
much that the u.s. won't have another
option but to put put it so around
probably that's I think that's that's
where we're headed the problem and again
another another the problems is that the
government is part of the problem so you
can go down there and negotiate with
this government but six years later it's
gonna be another government you got to
renegotiate with them yeah and also use
you palm grease yeah and then you put
all your faith in the military and the
military gets compromised you put all
the faith and the Mexican Marines and
then they get compromised and now who do
you have all right so it's systemic
don't tell that to trump
he'll use as an excuse we can't count on
them we're going in I I mean I wonder
where it all goes because it is
obviously growing very fast
it's obviously huge incredibly powerful
and and it affects I mean I'm up here
now and I could see the effects of it up
here walking through LA seeing all the
needles on the ground going to Seattle
seeing the same light brown
fentanyl-laced heroin that I saw in
shantytowns down Bob it's like wow so
this is where it kind of ends up oh yeah
so you said you see the effects of it
throughout so you know you you realize
quickly as somebody from both sides that
I am you realize that there
realistically there's no border there's
kind of no border when it comes to this
problem it was brought this this problem
doesn't respect a border wall right
right submarines will go around it
tunnels will go under it drones will fly
over it and it's a it's a problem that
just keeps you know producing an effect
and I think the majority of the
citizens are completely unaware of the
complexity and the depth of the problem
yeah I mean it is well it's in it's also
I think most people seeing the Iran
thing right now most people know more
about that oh yeah enough going on
halfway across the world
yeah then what's going on just you know
that's what's crazy to me it's like you
know we're we're into invading countries
that are really barely affecting us that
are like a 17 hour plane flight yeah I
think I think the again I don't I don't
want to be Ed Adamas and you know
predict stuff Eddie Thomas but the the
fact that we have a lot of lithium in
Sonora is going to be a factor for a
reason to clean it up it should be it
should be it's pretty important it's a
pretty important resource even if they
can't hold on the El Chapo's son
that's that's why I think us cos gonna
have to you know put foot sewing boots
on the ground down there Wow now if you
had to make a bet like if there's a
betting line in Vegas like how many how
many days or how many years from now
weirdly be American soldiers deployed to
Mexico I know I'd say five years maybe
whoa in five years really I mean Kurt we
we are on we just passed this this past
year has been the most violent year in
Mexico in recorded history really and
it's the first year of administration of
this new president right who's been
trying to hugs hugs how to not not
bullets I've wrestled over lasses you
know this instead of that
it's been his first year and you know
give him a chance he's doing whatever
he's only the most violent year in
history yeah cut the guy a break
exactly that's what they say but then I
go down there and I have a lot of a lot
of my friends that are still down there
people that I've trained still down
there and I hear from them directly like
I have some young kids that are in the
ten dollar Madea which is like a federal
police force that patrols all New Mexico
and some of the federal federal police
guys they tell me like head we're we
they said or you sign the new contract
to be the water than
- no and lower your pay and all your all
of the stuff that all your benefits will
be gone or you just stay on here and
limbo and just stay at the base and a
lot of them are staying at the base so
it's nothing nothing's nothing's
nothing's being done well I imagine that
if it seems overwhelming and it seems
helpless and it seems like the cartels
are just taking over and they're making
a shitload of money and you're not
making any money I mean that that is the
real crazy thing about right there if
the the government is asking people in
this sort of already compromised
situation environment asking them to
work for a small amount of money to go
after people that are making a
tremendous amount of money yeah and
you're gonna be a war with these people
these people they're basically your
neighbors yeah and also you go there
with a federal uniform much part of the
federal government you go into a
community where you the federal
government doesn't do anything for them
right the church is made by the cartels
cartel made the road Christmas was
brought brought to you by the cartels
you know they they are the good guys so
these guys come in here like with you
guys like what are they they are we're
not gonna so that's you know it's it's
it's it's it is it's it's a mess it's a
mess Wow but could boots on the ground
actually fix anything I mean I'm not a
I'm not a I'm not a military expert but
there has to be some sort of outside
force that is completely uncompromised
by kartell money and influence how long
before they compromise those people well
when you put the Marines on the border a
few of them got picked up on smuggling
people from the border so yeah that's
what I'm saying
it's it's and it's also it's a different
war field because a lot of you know a
lot of our war fighters and law
enforcement are have some sort of blood
ties to Mexico hmm
[Applause]